hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
perhaps one of the best known and most
popular ideas coming from freud's
tripartite psychology distinguishing
things
into superego ego and it is
exactly that the id
this notion of their being this blind
driving force within us that
does things without us knowing it's
largely unconscious and
we have to be careful to somehow tame it
and you know there is a nice little
passage in here where freud
says to adopt a popular mode of speaking
we might say that the ego stands for
reason and good sense while the id
stands for the
untamed passions and this is coming in
lecture
31 the dissection of the psychical
personality so we're dissecting out that
part
in in a way that's reminiscent for many
people
of plato's tripartite psychology
in in some respects it's actually closer
to other
ancient psychologies than it would be to
plato's
but this notion that there's like the
you know
conscious reasonable part of ourselves
that doesn't have that much energy and
then we've got this other part of
ourselves that
has you know the energy but no
organization
and is driven by its own appetites
toward its own driving towards and away
from things
that's a very uh common conception it's
not entirely
correct and freud is is uh very
keen to help us understand better
the nature and the role of the id
in his psychology in this lecture
so he begins by you know reiterating
this is not something absolutely new in
freud's work but that
we can call this the id or in german
the the s and the it is a little bit
more removed
for us english speakers from
what what we would normally talk about
it really could be just translated as
the it
the id is a latinate form you know freud
is also using ego
ego is i right so he tells us that it's
a
part of the personality alien to the ego
a little bit later of course he's also
going to tell us that the ego
develops from it draws upon it for
its sources of energy so the relation is
not
so simple as well there's this part of
ourselves we just simply don't
understand
and there are i would say in his
discussion here
four main characteristics that freud is
calling our attention to to help us
understand it so the first is that he
calls this a
dark inaccessible part
of the personality he says
what little we know of it we've learned
how from our study of the dream work so
you know the interpretation of dreams a
very thick work
he's also when he talks about the dream
work he's talking about what he does
with patients or clients getting them to
explain their dreams and this would also
have to do with you know
related things like free association
he also then talks about symptoms
and he tells us that the construction of
neurotic symptoms so what is
what does he mean there the construction
the way that they
are put together the way that we can
decipher them
and unpack them in the dialogical or
dialectical
relation between the therapist and the
person who is being analyzed right the
the analysis that in psychoanalysis
and then he tells us about analogies
and this is quite important analogies
are
linguistic and cognitive there are ways
in which we make sense out of
things that we can't fully express in
their own
terms so you know freud brings up
um he says we call it a chaos calling
something a chaos
is not a strictly speaking literal
statement right it's an analogy
uh we don't really know what a chaos is
like to begin with
maybe we've experienced some chaotic
circumstances
going into uh you know something that's
been demolished and looking around say a
bookstore that got bombed and
and that could be a chaos um but you
know these are likenings
a cauldron full of seething excitation
so a cauldron
that's something i think most of us can
quite so easily
relate to we could say a big cook pot
right in which we're putting things
and it's boiling over so we understand
the id
through trying to make sense of it
but we're never getting at it directly
you can't bring it
so to speak under the microscope
you can conceptualize it as a
agency of the human being a part of the
personality
but what you're doing there is using
images for something that's actually
quite dynamic
another key characteristic that he
points out
is that there's a lack of logical and
temporal even
spatial structuring going on so he tells
us
it has no organization produces no
collective will
only a striving to bring about
satisfaction
the logical laws of thought do not apply
to
the id now this is a kind of a big deal
at the time that freud
is writing and speaking the logical laws
of thought
when we talk about logic today a lot of
people actually just turn it into a
fetish you know the
science logic reason crowd right and
they don't actually know much about
logic
there was a prevalent tendency at the
time to consider
logic as a discipline to
encompass the laws of thought if we can
just get the laws of thought straight
then we can get rid of illogicalities
and and make our thinking more precise
better
more accurate and so the id doesn't do
that the id is not concerned with those
laws
you can propose those laws to the id and
the id will probably just eat them
or you know scratch itself on them or
throw them out the window uh you know if
you've ever watched
as i've been recently re-watching the
show
the young ones some of the characters in
there particularly vivian would be a
great example
of you know the id busting through
through the walls and shouting and doing
whatever it is that he chooses to do
at the time seemingly with no particular
logic and if you proposed you know laws
of logic to that then
it's not going to get any grasp he also
says this is true above all
of the law of contradiction so when we
talk about the laws
of thought we often talk about you know
law of excluded middle law of
contradiction we can come up with a
whole bunch of these in logic and that's
often what we teach in logic classes
freud says that the id does not respect
these
it's just not part of it so he says
contrary impulses exist side by side
without canceling each other
out or diminishing each other at most
they may converge to form
compromises under the dominating
economic pressure
towards the discharge of energy right
and he's not talking about economic in
the sense of you know world economy
or anything like that he's talking about
how
things are coming together to produce
certain results
he says there's nothing in the id that
could be compared with negation
and we perceive with surprise an
exception to the philosophical theorem
that space and time are necessary forms
of our mental act
again a very popular way of
looking at things that had bled into the
intellectual culture
kant for example had said that space and
time are forms of perception we're kind
of stuck with them
right and a lot of earlier philosophers
had more or less taken them for granted
we can go on and think about
contemporaries of freud like edmund
husserl
who are examining spatiality and
temporality
and how they appear to us and how
they're constituted you might take a
look at
hustle's passive synthesis lectures and
freud is saying no within the id this
doesn't
actually hold
how do we know this he says there's
nothing in the id that corresponds to
the idea of time
okay so the idea of time is not the same
thing as time that's a representation
of time but then he goes on and he says
there's no recognition of the passage
of time how is this evidenced if we
can't actually look at the id
directly well the things that happened
in the past that have remained
somehow within the id are just
as vivid today as they were 20 years
ago when we were you know punished
or lost an object or you know desired
something
and that desire was not fulfilled he
says
wishful impulses which have never passed
beyond the id but impressions too which
have sunk
into the id by repression are virtually
immortal after the passage of decades
they behave
as though they had just occurred
so that's quite an important point
to make there freud is really stressing
the
lack of temporality much more than the
spatial disorganization he'll talk about
you know
some of the things that he brings up in
the dreamwork condens condensation
displacement as being part of the
the way in which the id you know frames
things to
itself revealed for example through the
dreamwork
another key characteristic of the id is
that it's governed by what freud terms
the pleasure principle
doesn't define the pleasure principle in
this lecture because
it's a you know major concept within his
works
very simply put this is going to be a
little bit of a oversimplification the
pleasure principle
is that part of our you know our you
could call it makeup
that drives us to pursue what is
pleasant to us you know identify
something as pleasant and then want
more of it and more and more and more
and whatever is painful it says get that
the hell away from me
i don't want any more of that and so it
you know it's a very
baseline hedonist principle but as
opposed to
we could say philosophies of hedonism
for example epicureanism
there is no valorization of this
in the realm of morality or goodness
right instead it's just you pursue it
you you like the candy eat the candy eat
some more candy
you put the something bitter in your
mouth and taking a sip of your
your dad's beer when you're a little kid
and don't appreciate bitter things
you know you take a sip you spit it out
you're like i don't want any more of
that and you see the beer can you like
get that away from me
right that's the sort of thing that
freud is
talking about it goes all the way back
to nursing
and disliking being in a dirty diaper
whatever
whatever it's going to be so he he goes
on
and he says that the id knows
no judgments of value no good and evil
no morality the economic again he uses
that term
or if you prefer the quantitative factor
which is intimately linked to the
pressure principle
dominates all of its processes and here
he also brings in a technical term
he says instinctual cathexis seeking
discharge that is in our view all there
is
in the id so what is a cathexis
again another freudian term that he uses
it's something where we've you know
invested it
it with a certain kind of value not the
value that that leads us to morality
but something that you could say is
important for us that we
we notice and something can have you
know
a cathexis looking for as he says
discharge
there's other possibilities as well but
these are deep down within our id
and so you know think about uh when you
first
encounter sexuality and you realize that
there's enjoyment to be had
out of your own body well there's
cathexis there or
the experience of eating something sweet
or as later on you discover with
intoxicants so pick any other thing
that you want along those lines could be
fun just to like listen to certain kind
of
kind of music right so the it is driven
by these sorts of things it's also
driven by what has
been repressed uh into
the id and it's important to realize so
freud brought this up a little bit
earlier right but it's important to
realize
that when things are you could say push
down
into the end as he's going to say later
there's one portion of the id from which
the ego has separated itself
by resistances due to repression but the
repression
is not carried over into the id the
repressed
merges into the remainder of the it so
the it is just like this
massive space within us that has all
this
this stuff and images and energies going
on
that's another important characteristic
the
id is the locus
and the you might say orienter at least
at first
of all these instinctual energies
that we have and it supplies energy to
the ego and freud talks a little bit
about
how the ego can trick the id into giving
it more
energy and how you know the id itself
in some respects you know needs to be
steered by the ego
if the id was allowed to just run its
own show it would kill the
bearer of the id the the person the
human being right
the ego does an important mediating
function it needs to
rely on energies coming ultimately from
the id in order to do that
i do want to bring up something that
freud talks about at the very
end that in some respects represents
where psychoanalysis is going
there's this famous phrase that gets
made a lot of in interpretation of
psychoanalysis in the german it runs
voesvar slovekiverden and it's
translated here
where it was their ego shall
be now there's always a lot of
controversies shall be
you know for verdan because verdin is
also a word for becoming
and so maybe there's a little bit more
intentionality
here but that's that's framed as one of
the key
goals of psychoanalysis
and it tells us that this is a work of
culture
or or development and that's one of the
things that
psychoanalysis you know recommends to us
and recommends itself to us as a means
of carrying out as human subjects all of
whom have these
ids but we don't want to be just driven
by them
it's impossible to entirely eliminate
the it and that
wouldn't be the goal that would be
actually a foolish counterproductive
idea
but to replace significant portions of
it by bringing things into consciousness
and allowing us to then be you know able
to
exercise some agency of our own towards
them
that is a goal so hopefully this gives
you
some conception of what freud means by
the id it's a little bit more
than the popular conception that often
gets put forward of just this blind
driving force
that is you know destructive it's
actually
you know there's a lot of features and
sides to it
and it doesn't really have any
organization
in the sense that we're used to but it
but it does have
you know a number of different things
going on within it
you